people don't exactly line up for the
newest version of Google devices as
opposed to the Apple iPhone well to be
sure these devices are not made by
Google's that's part of it the software
isn't that's the important thing these
are huawei phones or LG phones and drink
called following that way you know yeah
I mean it's a different business model
and so maybe the marketing model is not
going to quite match it as well you know
the notion of Android fundamentally is
to propagate a software system that
sends users back to Google for other
services at Google gets paid for now
that of course the subject of an FCC
investigative TC investigation Justice
Department investigation right now over
our the way is that Google might be
using Android to gain an unfair
advantage over other companies trying to
write software for smartphones a big
issue for Google one they surely did not
discuss in today's press event has a new
Nexus phone mind you I don't have that's
exactly my point you don't have a new
Nexus phone no one has a new who has a
new Nexus phone I mean I mean they
thanked invisible I'm sure but do they
have do they sell 13 million over a
weekend isn't that how many Apple
managed to sell if it's new iphone 6
apple so it's interesting that the
economies of scale that work for Apple
developing a single device we're
actually two devices right the 6s and
the 6s plus in the latest model they're
able to achieve hardware economies of
scale let alone the software right let's
let's assume the software development
costs are equal at both Google and Apple
we don't really know and we'll never
know because I'm not breaking those
numbers out but we soon the software
costs the same to develop and the
feature sets might be the same the
hardware advantages that that Apple can
get on economies of scale making their
own chips using chips from companies
like skyworks or avago or others is
sizable and it lets them have a product
that's very hard to compete with with
Google though there are more androids
phones sold to be sure than google
phones but there's more pressure than
Apple phones but there's more profit and
Apple phones and there are in the phones
of the Android that's kind of important
isn't it profit they make more make more
money yeah it's not a bit not these days
does Google family grow sales for weight
and that's a different story will go
there data does Google need to make
money on its phones on Android to
accomplish what it wants to do which is
bring more people into the ecosystem so
the world is chained
from a war where computing is happening
on these things right where and it still
is to be sure if one that ever wrote a
headline that says the pc is dead wrote
it on a pc but as more and more
computing as happening a mobile
environment you know google very
cleverly saw this coming from a long
ways off and realize if they wanted
their dominant company on the desktop to
port to the new computing environment
they had to be central to the operating
systems of this new environment the
problem is when you do a search on
opentable probably your favorite app
well anyway go ahead yeah right whatever
yeah good hockey games right you
probably don't you probably saw with the
snap snap your big snapchat person oh
you don't go to google to search for
snapchat you don't go on your phone and
search for google for opentable you go
right to the app that's a problem for
google because people don't begin their
searches google com with apps it's a
different world out there